the winner of the organizing Awards this
year is Bella fashola of rmt
[Applause]
[Applause]
and the winner of the learning rep award
this year is Catherine Williams from
Unite
[Applause]
foreign
ER of the young members award is Lewis
Acres of ngsu
the final award is the women's gold
badge and this year's recipient is Carol
Sewell of Unison unfortunately Carol
can't be with us today but I'm sure
you'll join me in congratulating her and
we'll make sure that she gets her Awards
safely
[Applause]
thank you I call paragraph 5.6
and colleagues I now like to welcome
this morning's keynote speaker the
leader of the labor party Kirsten
at Labor's conference last month Kia set
out how a labor government would deliver
a new deal for working people a vital
part of Labor's plan to build a fairer
Greener future and this of course is in
Stark chaos stark contrast to the chaos
of the current government which seems to
get worse by the minute
we look forward to hearing more from
care today about his vision and about
how labor will work with unions to
support working people through the cost
of living crisis and promote workers and
Trade union rights Kia you're very
welcome I invite you to address Congress
[Applause]
thank you sue thank you Congress and
it's a privilege to come and speak to
you at such an important time I have to
say with everything going on I'm a bit
nervous to turn my phone off for half an
hour 45 minutes we really don't know
what will have happened by the time we
turn it back on can I just say watching
that video and hearing the words of the
Reps there was really moving I think a
real reminder of the importance of the
Trade union movement but look before I
go any further I want to say thank you
to the general secretary my friend a
giant of the labor movement Francis
on the side of workers on the side of
women
on the side of Arsenal
Francis is always on the right side
but Congress especially during the
pandemic
where her determination to fight for
working people was an inspiration to all
of us
Congress never forget
it was Francis who led the employers and
the government to the furlough scheme
a tripartite deal for those troubled
times a true Collective Agreement for
the nation
without her deal 10 million workers
would have been jobless during a
Monumental social crisis
and my labor party supported it every
step of the way including on the many
occasions the government wanted to scrap
it prematurely
we will never forget that leadership
Francis thank you for that
and thank you to Paul too
the organizing you did to keep workers
safe during the crisis saved countless
lives
I know how much our movement is in your
blood
I also know
that you're an Everton fan
so as the TUC moves from red to blue
I look forward to working with you as
Britain moves in the opposite direction
Congress today I want to set out what's
at stake for Britain
because while politics is always about
choices
the choice now is as Stark As It Gets
we Face a battle for the soul of our
country
Who We Are
who we're for
the labor choices of Britain that is
fairer Greener and more dynamic
a Britain where we rebuild our public
services to provide opportunity and
security
climate emergency head on
use it to create jobs and industries of
the future restore faith in politics as
a Force for good get Britain's hope its
confidence and its future back
but the first step
Foundation that all this rests on
is respect for the working people who
create the wealth that drives our
country forward
it's not just the privileged few who
grow Britain's economy the tourists are
so wrong about that
nurses teachers Engineers physios
scientists shop workers drivers Builders
bartenders teaching assistants
technicians Cooks warehouse workers
posters Farmers small business owners
who grows our economy
whose growth for
the right choice the only choice the
labor choice
is working people
and my government will be dedicated to
building an economy that works for
working people
everything else flows from this
and Britain knows exactly where the
tourists stand
they can dance around a new turn
they can sack this Chancellor or the
prime minister
but the damage is done and they did it
they crashed the British economy
and for what to show they were on the
side of the richest one percent
a crisis made in Downing Street without
a democratic mandate paid for by working
people in higher bills higher rents and
higher mortgages
this is who they are
these are their true colors
never again can Britain take seriously
their claim to be a party of aspiration
or sound money
but Congress
last night in Parliament
even by their standards
a new chaotic low
all the failures of the past 12 years
have now come to the boil
the victims of crime who can't get
Justice
people dying because ambulances can't
get there in time
Millions going without food or Heating
and none of it can drum into the Tories
the idea
that our country must come first
they lack the basic patriotic duty to
keep the British people out of their own
pathetic squabbles
and it's wrecked the finances of our
country and for millions of people
this cannot continue
Britain deserves better
Britain cannot afford the chaos of the
conservatives anymore we need a general
election now
[Music]
Congress
just look at their latest plan
to get our country out of the hole that
zadab
they turn to austerity
they turn to you
to your members and their rights
Congress
I'm sure you've heard that tape
how the Prime Minister thinks that
working people lack skill and
application
heard her say that your members don't
graft hard enough
it's delusional it's insulting
but it comes with a warning
because look around the country
a National Emergency on the cost of
living Public Services on their knees
working people drafting every minute of
the day still unable to make ends meet
and ask yourself this
with that warped logic in charge
what happens when the tourists finally
see the full reality of what they've
done
I'll tell you
they'll Lush out
Double Down
attacked my party our movement and your
members
so Congress let me stand here and spell
this out
if they bring forward further
restrictions on workers rights or the
right to strike we will oppose and we
will repeal
conference just as we will tear up
anti-trade Union legislation such as the
Trade union Act 2016.
absolutely
but we also need to be prepared
disciplined relentlessly focused on the
future meet their attacks with hope
provide the leadership this country so
desperately needs
and build a Britain where working people
can succeed again where working people
are backed as the people who really
create economic growth
that's the labor choice
and that's not just words
I don't come from a privileged
background
I grew up in a pebble-semi in the 1970s
I remember what the anxiety of rising
prices feels like
remember when our phone was cut off
because we couldn't pay the bill
and I know what that anxiety looks like
now
let me tell you about a care worker I
know
she works 14-hour shifts often overnight
never flinching at the Relentless
pressures put upon her
and every week yes every week she
struggles to make ends meet
Congress that care worker
is my sister
and when I think about the work that she
and millions like her did for our
country during the pandemic risking
their health to save lives on low pay
low Security Contracts and the Prime
Minister says that the problem is people
like my sister lat graft
let me spell it out
the fight for fair pay the fight for
good work the fight to make our economy
work for everyone not just a privileged
View
is personal for me
and I will not rest until we see a
Britain based on those values that's the
labor choice
if you don't back people like my sister
don't be surprised if you get 12 years
of stagnant growth
that's why we backed working people on
Rising Energy prices
when the Prime Minister argued against
handouts labor provided the clarity the
nation needed we said this winter not a
penny more on anyone's bills and we'd
make sure the oil and gas companies pay
their fair share
and I'll tell you something else we'd
abolish non-dom status to get our NHS
back on its feet
foreign
that's the main barrier to capacity
right now staff
so we would invest in more doctors more
nurses more Health visitors
a tax break for some of our richest in
our society or a stronger NHS Workforce
that is not a hard choice for us
but to end this cost of living crisis
once and for all
we also need a long-term plan
a plan that will deliver cheaper bills
and higher energy standards for working
people
growth and jobs in all parts of the
country
and real independence from tyrants like
Putin who weaponize fossil fuel exports
and threaten our security
that's what our green Prosperity plan
will achieve
a hundred percent clean Power by 2030.
investment in Wind solar nuclear
hydrogen green steel and carbon capture
training for plumbers electricians
Engineers software designers technicians
builders
a national Sovereign wealth fund that
generates growth and private investment
insulation for 19 million homes and
Great British energy a publicly owned
company that takes advantage of the
opportunities in clean British power and
turns them into good secure high paid
British jobs
the argument for our plan is simple
green energy is already cheaper than
fossil fuels nine times cheaper
working people need more of it
Britain needs to own it
and the jobs and growth we generate must
be shared with every community
that's the labor choice
it's why I've always said we'll fight
the Tories on economic growth
the prime minister is completely out of
touch with the reality of the British
economy
she thinks workers rights and collective
bargaining are a barrier to growth
she doesn't care about the distribution
of wealth in Britain she hasn't you
turned on that
it's a clear argument I'll give her that
but it's one we've heard before
and it doesn't work
working people will not be better off
because we make the rich richer it's
pure Dogma the world has moved on from
these discredited ideas
and every day the tourists stick to them
is another nail in the coffin of
Britain's economic credibility
our real problem
is we create too many jobs
that are low paid and insecure
we lock too many communities out of the
wealth that we create
and our Public Services aren't strong
enough to help working people succeed
why we struggle to grow
our economic conditions are too weak
and the Tory argument is
that's fine
if the city of London races ahead and
the rest of Britain stagnates they think
that's okay
Congress forget about lines on a graph
if you leave this many people behind a
nation will not grow fairly
you can't do it with low wages
you can't do it with insecure jobs and
bad work
and you can't do it without a modern
industrial strategy this isn't a debate
the evidence is in
a vicious cycle of stagnation
that's how the now former Chancellor
called it
and on this one thing he was right
12 years of story stagnation
have left the average British family
eight thousand eight hundred pounds
poorer than other advanced economies
economies like France Germany and the
Netherlands
economists that do have stronger
collective bargaining do have stronger
workers rights do have a fairer share of
wealth across their country
these things are not a barrier to growth
or higher productivity they go hand in
hand with it
labor choice
so we will strengthen the role of trade
unions in our society
an economy that is strong for working
people can't weaken the institutions
that give working people strength
and it cannot be built on insecure
foundations
security at work is the Bedrock for
aspiration and opportunity
for giving people the confidence to get
on
nobody does their best if they're racked
by fear about the future if their
contract gives them no protection to
stand up for their rights at work
or if proper safety net doesn't support
them in times of sickness and poor
health
that's what Labor's New Deal for working
people is all about
that's why we'll end fire and rehire ban
Zero Hour contracts extend parental
leave strengthen flexible working better
protection for pregnant women mandatory
reporting on ethnicity pay gaps
statically sick pay for all a single
worker status no more one-sided
flexibility
and Congress
so far as I'm concerned that's not just
a list of Rights
it's a statement of intent on social
justice on fairness whose side we're on
more security for every worker in our
country
and because of that a stronger
foundation for working people to Aspire
and get on that's the economic dynamism
Britain needs that's how you get growth
that's the labor choice
a choice that provides the basis for
True social Partnerships
a modern industrial strategy where we
unite tackle the country's challenges on
behalf of working people
I will say this here
I'm not just pro-business I want to
partner with business to drive Britain
forward
and I'll say the same about trade unions
to the CBI
you saw the deal Francis struck during
the pandemic the results speak for
themselves
it's a model Mark Drake for the Jews
successfully in Wales
and it can work
because the vast majority of Business
Leaders don't buy into the Tory
trickle-down fantasy
they're not knocking on my door saying
they want to rip up employee rights
they don't tell me the problems that
they face will be solved by corporation
tax cuts
they want Fair taxes High skills and the
long-term stability to invest
we can work with that we will work with
that
we'll set up a new industrial strategy
Council a permanent part of the
landscape that brings in the creative
genius of Science in our universities
holds us to account on our decisions
helps businesses to innovate and grow
and delivers a real partnership between
government business and unions this is
how we can give Britain the stability it
needs for higher investment a long-term
plan
not a short-term fix
that's the labor choice
but when we talk about economic
stability
I want to be frank
the damage that Tories have done to our
finances and our Public Services means
things are going to be really tough
now and during my labor government
we cannot take any risks with the public
finances
we have to restore economic stability be
the party of sound money
you've all seen the damage that can be
done from fiscal irresponsibility
when you lose control of the economy as
the Tories have done
you lose the ability to do anything
and working people pay the price that
will not happen with labor I will not
let it
it doesn't mean we have to take a back
seat on Fair pay
low pay is the biggest barrier to a
fairer more Dynamic Britain bar none
a huge drag on our prospects for growth
and social justice
we need a minimum wage that reflects the
cost of living
and with a labor government that is
exactly what Britain will get
but
we will go further
because ending low pay in Britain isn't
just a cushion of law it's not about the
rules the state sets
it's about the power working people have
to shape the rules that govern their
lives
so my labor government will end the Tory
race to the bottom on pay with Fair pay
agreements
agreements that will make work pay for
the people who create Britain's economic
growth
just think how this would work in Social
care
to where half a million workers are paid
less than the 10 pounds an hour
where people have to work multiple jobs
and still struggle to provide for their
family
with our Fair pay agreements social care
employers and unions will have to get
around the table and negotiate and the
deal they strike will set the floor for
every social care employer in the
country that's how you make work pay
fairly
that's how you improve conditions and
raise the status of care work respect
the workers who say countless lives in
the pandemic and create this country's
wealth
good work
Fair pay respect
that's the labor choice
it's what both of us fight for party and
movement
but we must fight in different ways must
accept that when it comes to delivering
for working people we have different
jobs
I support the right to strike
unequivocally
I understand it's always a last resort
the Tory idea that working people give
up their wages lightly in the worst cost
of living crisis for a century is
completely unserious about the pain
people feel right now
you're representing the Democratic
choice of your members you're doing your
job and I respect that
but my job is different the single most
important thing I can do for working
people is to make sure we win the next
election and get a labor government
that is how we roll out our green
Prosperity plan how we deliver the New
Deal for working people can we create a
modern industrial strategy together none
of this happens unless labor is in power
so I will never be ashamed to say my
labor party wants to increase worker
power in our economy
but nor will I apologize for approaching
questions on Industrial action as a
potential labor government the labor
party is not doing its job when it's in
opposition
I will not let this be an era of Tory
chaos stagnation attacks on working
people we can't go on any longer
this can't be a rerun of the 1980s
that's what they want
this trust has torn away the veil
they're not even pretending anymore
the Battle Is Here
a battle where all the usual signs of
Tory decay
troubling public services that run on
the pound the question about how we keep
the lights on
and the brutal hit to living standards
of pensioners families and the poorest
in our society well
click on us
Congress
have no doubt about what's coming
take nothing for granted
this winter will be brutal
we must do everything we can to look
after people
Tories will not give up on power that's
not who they are
our country is crying out for decisive
leadership
and labor will provide it we will work
every day to earn the trust of the
British people meet their Ambitions for
Real Change walk towards a better future
and put this Tory trickle down nonsense
back in its box once and for all that's
the choice for Britain
a Tory party that's lost control of
itself and the economy or a labor
government that delivers Fair pay good
work and prosperity for all a country
where aspiration is rewarded a clean
energy superpower a fair Adrena more
Dynamic Britain where working people get
their rights respect and security that
they deserve that's the labor choice
thank you Congress
thank you Congress
thank you congrats
[Applause]
thank you
thank you key that was a wonderful
speech and know that you have the full
support of the Trade union movement
I'd now like to call delegates to put
their questions to care I'm going to
call you in threes to ask your questions
and when we've heard the three questions
we'll hand over to care to respond
so we've got to start with calling Sam
hemraj from Unison Mandy Naylor from
other door and Bella fashola from rmt
Prince Public Service workers including
those of us in the NHS are bone the
brunt of Tory austerity not least with
the hit on our pay packet by the end of
October NHS key workers across the UK
will be deciding if they will be
striking for better pay and staff in
this winter labor in opposition has
shown its support for public services
but what will labor do in power to
ensure that in future our members in the
NHS and other public services receive
pay awards that are in least in line
with inflation thank you
thank you Sam
good morning
our question is willstar survey there to
show us that one in four Universal
Credit clearance are missing meals every
month just to pay the bills with one in
five having to buy on food banks
low-paid workers have been failed by
Universal Credit under the target
austerity program
the system is not fit for purpose and
does not structured sorry has not been
structured in a way that supports law
paid workers
how will the labor party put pressure on
the terrorists to increase all benefits
in line with inflation and what plans
does the labor party have to work with
trade unions and to deliver a social
security system which provides an
adequate safety net for the contract
thank you
thank you Mandy
hello Kia brother for Charlotte r t
Union firstly can I thank you for all
you did working with the rmt to fight
the p o seconds and support our
seafaring colleagues
I myself I'm a railway cleaner and my
job is outsourced to a company called
Churchills because we are outsourced we
get worse conditions of employment and
outsourced workers are overwhelmingly
Fame and women workers will you promise
to stick to your new deal for workers so
that thousands of outsourced public
transport transport workers like myself
can be brought back in-house
thank you Bella
let me let me deal with those up three
starting with the NHS and the question
that Sam put to me and firstly just let
me say thank you to all of those who
work in NHS and all our public services
for everything they do every day
particularly during the pandemic
Congress as you probably know my wife
works in the NHS my mum worked in the
NHS my sister worked in the HS and my
wife's mother worked in the NHS so it
runs through my body like my DNA and we
know that it's not just the strain of
the last few years there's 12 years
worth of strain in that now what will we
be able to do in power the first thing
is to broaden the remit of the pay
review bodies to put additional emphasis
on pay reflecting the need for improved
Recruitment and Retention but we also
need to grow our economy and that's why
what I said in my speech and what we
said at conference is really important
because we intend to abolish non-doms
and to use that money to double the
number going into our medical schools
Etc to build up our public services to
make that choice
but thirdly what we've got to do is to
tackle inflation because the cost of
living crisis is going to go on for some
time if we don't get inflation under
control and that's why our energy
package was so important and making sure
that we answer the question if you're
going to freeze people's bills who pays
for that and it's got to be a fair share
from the excess profit of the oil and
wind companies and it's really hard to
believe that list trust is really saying
that we're going to freeze energy bills
for six months but she's not going to
ask the oil and gas companies who made
profits they didn't expect to make to
pay anything towards it she's going to
put it on the Never Never which means
your members will pay for it in
additional taxes for years and years to
come so Sam we've got a big program for
public services when we get into
government and I look forward to working
with you to take that forward
Mandy
um on benefits in line with inflation
first thing is the statistics uh that
you just quoted are absolutely awful in
terms of the number of people in real
property now
um and um we have to take this on we
believe that benefits should go up in
line with inflation and the government
used to believe that until a few days
ago
so we will write in the short term we
will work with Tori MPS who feel
strongly about this to make sure that we
put up a United opposition in Parliament
to what the government is proposing
in the longer term I do think that we
need to reform aspects of our benefit
system where they're not working and I
know Jonathan Ashworth is already
starting work with the trade unions on
that and we'll continue uh to do so but
I mean there is one final Point Mandy I
would make which is
um we do have to ask ourselves this goes
back to my argument on growth and pay we
do have to ask ourselves why in this
country we have so many working people
who are also reliant on benefits because
they simply aren't paid enough money
that is shocking and that's why we need
to grow the economy have secure
well-paid jobs for so many millions of
people who are struggling just at the
moment
um Bella on um the questions of um the
new deal for workers and piano firstly
um thank you for everything that you and
the union and trade unions did generally
in relation to that piano dispute I met
a number of those um who lost their jobs
in that disgraceful action by piano they
came to see me they talked me through
they had years and years and years of
experience in the job that they did and
when they came to see me they were
extremely concerned about the loss of
their job what it meant for them their
family and their Community but I tell
you what their main concern was that the
boat or ship that they'd been working on
wouldn't be safe
that was what they talked to me around
the table about that was their concern
that they were being replaced by
inexperienced people and it would put
those on the boats and ships at Sea in
danger and that was the motivation for
them it was really fantastic
um to meet them but it shows you why we
need
um the new deal for workers and we are
absolutely committed to that Bella we've
got it drafted we had at a conference
last year and we're committed to
implementing it within the first 100
days of the next Labor government so
thank you very much for that question
care I now call Taj shalam from the
night Carol Robertson from GMB and Gary
Elliott from Nautilus
Ikea thank you
unite the Union
I'm a bus driver and a unite Branch
Secretary unite has won 64 bus strikes
in the last year
after profitable employers initially
refused to pay decent pay Rises
do you agree that when profitable
employers with ability to pay try to
impose pickups on workers those workers
are right to take industrial action
[Applause]
Carol Robertson from the GMB hi Carol my
sons are looking for work and one of the
few local employers is Amazon
I am extremely concerned for their
safety if they do have to work there
are very real accounts of oppressive
pick rates two short breaks and injuries
and a culture of surveillance and job
insecurity no employer in this DNA day
and age should be treating workers this
way
will labor promised to deny Amazon any
public sector contracts including for
Amazon web services until I sort it out
it's appalling health and safety record
and ended its aggressive hostility to
trade Union
[Applause]
good morning Gary Elliott hey Nautilus
International the seafarers Union
um in March 786 British seafarers were
unlawfully dismissed by piano ferries
without consultation or notice
p l ferries factored into the cost of
breaking the law when they decided to
sack almost their entire British crew
had a coincidence from what you just
said about the Dutch they never sat one
Dutch Seafarer because of their
employment rights which are far stronger
than the UK additionally UK law does not
provide for conjunctive relief
um will the labor government put that
right
thank you um
[Applause]
thank you thank you let me deal with
those Taj firstly let me thank bus
drivers for everything they do
particularly during the pandemic I met
the daughter of ranjith who you will
remember was the bus driver who died
from covid from doing his job as a bus
driver so I know firsthand just how hard
that was during the pandemic and when it
comes to Industrial action obviously
that's an incredible record for unite in
terms of the strikes and the
negotiations and what they've won for
their members and quite right too we
have to understand
the suffering of so many people whose
wages haven't gone up for a very very
long time and prices are going through
the roof and they can't make ends meet
and that's why that action is taken and
that's the role of trade unions to take
on that action and I support the right
to strike I do think that there's much
more we can do when it comes to bus bus
services and bus drivers I was with our
Metro Mayors Andy in Manchester Steve up
in Liverpool and Tracy brabin now in
West Yorkshire and what they're driving
towards when it comes to buses is this
idea of a flat fare plus control over
the routes that are used for buses and I
think that's the sort of thing that an
incoming labor government could
absolutely push forward not just where
we've got Metro Mayors but across the
whole of the country so thank you Taj
for that Carol in relation to Amazon
firstly I'm really concerned by the
issues that GMB have raised in relation
to Amazon some of which you mentioned in
your question but there are plenty of
other examples I do think it's the role
of government to drive up standards I
don't think government should just get
out of the way it's the role of
government to do so that's why our new
deal for working people is so important
day one rights for every worker whatever
their status that would make a huge
difference when it comes to Amazon I do
think there's other things things an
incoming labor government can do there's
a lot of procurement and it's up to a
government to put terms and conditions
and a framework around procurement to
make it clear the standards we would
expect if public money is going to be
expended on any uh business whether it's
Amazon or anybody else but I would say
this uh Carol you know I'll be very
clear to you and to Amazon they should
recognize the GMB and have a unionized
Workforce it's as simple as that
and Gary
on piano obviously I've said one or two
things about it before what really
frustrated all of us in relation to that
appalling series of suckings was that
the provision in the law they used to do
it was pointed out as a gap two years
before they did it the government knew
there was a gap they knew they had to
close that Gap they didn't do it and pno
sailed right through it
and the government's done nothing about
it we would take that on we would change
that law close that Gap and put it with
our package of employment rights within
the first hundred days of a labor
government that was absolutely
disgraceful what they did it was flagged
to the government the government did
nothing and pno then took advantage of
that we cannot allow that to happen
again and the comparison with other
countries is very very valid so thank
you for that question
okay thanks very much for taking the
time to answer those questions
just before we let you go I'm going to
abuse the chair because as you might
expect we had lots of other questions
from unions so many of our public sector
unions are dealing with the consequences
of vicious Cuts unstable Staffing levels
and real terms pay cuts University
lecturers civil servants teachers early
years workers health workers and others
all in the midst of industrial action
ballots or considering action and of
course some like the POA members in
England are even denied the basic right
to in to Industrial action even though
their colleagues in Scotland can take
industrial action
so what would a future labor government
do to invest in our public services and
heal the relationship between
politicians and hard-working public
servants who feel they just can't take
anymore how do we rebuild our Public
Services well Sue thank you for that
question and as most people who will
know I ran a public service for five
years with seven thousand staff and I
know what it means to be a public
servant because it means you go to work
you work hard and you have that public
service ethos that goes with it always
doing the extra work and it breaks my
heart to see what's happened to our
Public Services over the last 10 years I
saw what austerity did 10 years ago we
cannot do it again we cannot take cuts
to our public services and this is a
fight we'll have to have before we get
into government I fear because that's
exactly where this government is going
to go and we will resist it every step
of the way and with public services
um you know particularly the NHS I often
say
um you know they're on their knees a lot
of people working in public services say
no care they're actually down on their
face now it's that bad so we have to
make a mission of the next Labor
government to rebuild our Public
Services it goes with growth and the
idea that you could either have growth
economic growth or public services
completely wrong you can't have growth
without public services and vice versa
we have to see them as one part of the
same argument how we build a better
economy that works for working people
and how we build a better Britain for
the future so so that's what we will do
a national mission to rebuild our public
services and I look forward to working
with you and all the trade unions in
this room as we go down that path to
rebuild our public service would be one
of the best things that next Labor
government can achieve thank you sue
thank you Congress
thank you kid thank you
thank you for joining us and we look
forward to seeing you in Downing Street
[Applause]
Congress we now return to section three
of the general Council report good
Services the section on Justice on page
35.
I call motion 61 defending the Integrity
of the justice system
The General Counsel support the motion
it will be moved by Napo and seconded by
the POA
yes good morning congression Lawrence
General Secretary Napo moving motion 61.
well look we should have